i growed up i was way into yours we had
outside toilet
we dropped water rather well we milked
cows
we growed up tough but we made it
all right randy yeah randy uh where'd
you grow up where are you from
originally
i'm from eastern kentucky right here in
this old hollers furlock fort
dana kentucky this is floyd county this
is floyd county yes it is
i grew up by here on the old farm
tell me tell me about your childhood you
had both your parents growing up yes i
had my mother and daddy johnny acres and
margie acres was my mom and dad
we growed up they were seven children
we didn't have any running water we
didn't have no bathroom in the house
we dropped water from mom to wash
clothes on old wranger washer
dab worked in a coal mine from daylight
to dark
he raised us here on the farm he raised
what we eat
he raised hogs chicken cattle
we plowed the old garden with the old
mew
me and my brother when we got old enough
we plowed we hold
we took care of the farm while dad
worked
mom she was a housewife
she took care of the house and all the
washing and cleaning
we grew up poor
but you know that was the best life we
ever had growing up
because we know what it meant to live
you had to work you had to raise your
food you couldn't run to the store and
back
and when we got up in the way up new
year's
i remember we got some running water in
the old house
all that was the best thing ever
happened to us was running water
then they pitched in and they built mama
bathroom
that tickled my mom to death because she
was never had nothing like that you had
our house up until then we had an
outhouse yes we called it the old toilet
what is an outhouse it's just a a place
that you go to the bathroom and the
water the the
water the waste you build it over the
creek or stream is what i call it so the
way the waste goes into the creek
weights went in the creek and as time
grew you know
things uh was different i remember
having an old tv line up the hill
you got one channel channel three
we would go to school during the day we
come home in the evening
that's the first thing we do is hit that
hill to turn that antenna so we could
watch channel three
that's all we had and as time went on
they finally got tv cable and phone all
that stuff
i remember the first phone he ever had
was called a party line you had to get
on it first because
if you didn't you didn't get a talk
as time got farther along
dad had to quit work you know
our for years we struggled again
but you know i can thank god he took
care of us
he kept us all together as our family
we worked hard but till the day i still
work hard
i keep my audition going as my dad asked
me
son keep buying hogs killing hogs raise
your family right
i've raised three daughters pretty well
on my own
i'm well satisfied the way they turned
out
with your wife no no i i divorced my
wife i raise my kids
by myself with my sister and my
their niece my niece they helped me
raise them girls
but we raised all three of them by now
they know what it means to live i try to
keep
things just the way that dad had it back
when i growed up
so why did the mom not keep the kids
that's typically how it goes well
basically because the mom got on drugs
and you know
that's one thing i don't do yes i've had
four back surgeries
i'm i'm the first to tell you but you
never turn to drugs
because drugs will kill you that's how
the drugs kind of took hold here in this
room i have lost a lot of my best
friends that i went to school with on
countdown
and you know i will not turn to that
i like i said i've had four back
surgeries
i thank god every day that i still make
it
and i don't have to rely yes i hurt but
you got to go on with your life
i tell my daughters they work all the
time
the main thing is to take care of
yourself and make sure
that you've got food to eat because you
know
as the old sam we're not going to be
here all the time to protect them and
take care of them
my daughter lives wing now she stays
here
but she can kill hogs she can kill
chickens just as good as i can
because i've taught her that my other
daughter she lives in georgetown
and i don't see her as much as i like to
you know but you've got to go where
you can work the work population here is
way down
what kind of jobs have you had in your
life i've been a coal miner all my life
mister
i worked all my life in the coal mines
and i have really done well you know
but i i got more had poor back surgeries
like i said
and i keep going i tend my garden
just like i always did but i like
love to go back and and plow the garden
with the old horse or the old mew
like we used to but anymore it's all
about a roller tiller
and a tractor but i like to get away
from that and go back to
that way i was raised up doing it
because it was a lot better that back
then i thought
you know we worked hard i i growed up i
worked
all my life when i was a young kid i
worked
and all my brothers and my sisters they
worked too
well how far did you go in school i
graduated from high school at betsy lane
i went down here to the old prader
school to the
uh and graduated down there i guess from
eighth grade
and then we had to go to betsy lane but
they closed that operator school down
down there now
what do you think it is about appalachia
that that makes people here so special
is is it the struggle the hard the hard
i believe it's a struggle
you know people in this area they work
together
if i do something my neighbors helped me
if they do something i go help them
me and my two buddies down the road yes
we raise corn
we plant it by hand we pick it by hand
but that's how we was raised up doing
stuff like that
and you know like i said i enjoy doing
that stuff
and uh you know i just i just wish we
could go back
and do things different you know
growing up but you know that was the
good days we couldn't change
anything if we wanted to that's how it
was meant to be
do you think all this technology and all
the advancements in the world have
set us off on the wrong course
yeah i think so i think you know it had
nothing personally but i think when he
went to
cell phones and computer stuff that's
when things went down
you know i could be wrong i don't know
but that's just my belief i don't own a
cell phone
i don't own a computer because in my
knowledge
i don't know how to work stuff like that
told you i'm 60 years old
what was the best part of your life best
time of your life growing up as a kid
growing up as a kid and helping kill
hogs kill chicken
calves whatever that's how we raise our
garden
can our canned food and raise our
potatoes
that was my best days of my life growing
up
with all my my mom and dad and my
brother and brothers and my sister that
that was the good days
and you know uh me and my family
is still close me and my brother my
sisters
we're still real close
you describe yourself as happy oh yes
yes you seem to be
yes i'm happy yeah have you ever left
no i've never left kentucky here no i
you know i've been on vacation busy but
i always want to come home to kentucky
what happens when you leave eastern
kentucky you i miss it
it's always i'm wanting to get home yeah
because there's no place like home as
my saying what are the
worst parts about living here well i
mean
do you have did you have a car when you
were a kid uh no
no no we didn't i was probably 16 years
old when i first got my first bicycle
i was probably not and how would your
parents get around
or how would you get around well my dad
had an old truck and he drove to work
that's how
if we went anywhere we all got in the
back and went in the back of the truck
that was when you were 16 though yeah
but i'm saying before that
well that's how we got around then or we
walked or we rolled a horse that's what
i'm saying yeah yeah
so if you didn't have a car you were
using a horse yeah yeah
but that was the good days are you
religious
uh i go to church yes some
but not like i should
and you have friends oh yes i got a
olan's a friend
yeah what are you proudest of
well just growing up and seeing my kids
grow up
your kids are doing well oh yes they
real they do real good
yep all three of them all three girls
and they do excellent i'm really proud
of them how they growed up
that's great but they've been taught to
grow up this way
yeah you said a good role model you're a
good role model
yes everybody tells me that they a lot
of my buddies tell me
you've done great raise them you know
when i was a young man i wanted to go
out here and do stuff
but i had a responsibility kids that was
my responsibility
and i took care of them do you have any
regrets in life
uh not really i just you know
i enjoyed life because you don't know
if it's a day tomorrow you don't know
when life's over
just you know you got to be ready to eat
when it's over
i think you know the poverty you you've
endured as a child
was kind of across the board everybody
in this region is in the same boat
right so you didn't really feel poor did
you no no
we was all disalike i tell my kids about
today
we growed up if you got a pop
it was a special occasion because they
didn't have money to buy
we we me and my brother we milk cows
that's how we got our milk for many many
years
and like i said we had our own chickens
we milked our own cows
we done it all that's how we growed up
that's what make you respect
life you know how you growed up
and tell me about working as a coal
miner i mean that's a very rough job
right
dangerous well it's very dangerous i
work
six days a week 10 12 14 hours a day
since i when i turned 18 years old
i went to work in the coal mines because
that's all there was there were no other
options
no other options and i worked many many
years for the same company
like i said it's about three or four
miles from here
you know but it was a great job it was
great people to work for they treated
you with respect you know i'm sure we
made a millions of dollars
but that's what we was there for
it kept the whole region alive oh yes it
supported all the businesses all the
everything
yes and now that that's dried up we had
two little grocery stores here on the
creek when i growed up and went to grade
school down here
you could go and eat lunch there they
didn't have a lunchroom at our grade
school
you'd eat lunch mom and dad had a credit
setup you get 35 cents worth of stuff
but a lot of times for 35 cents you
couldn't eat everything you got
now you can't get a pop for 35 cents you
know times has
changed yeah but but your uh
the income for this region is pretty
much the same as it's been back in the
late 70s
people people people aren't making more
money and yet everything costs more
true very true you don't make a lot more
money this day and time
because it takes a lot more to leave a
lot of people are living off the
government
yes yes because there's no coal mining
jobs and there's no
other options right what do you worry
about
well i don't worry about anything you
know i love to see my two grandkids
raised but i know they gotta find mom
and dad i know they will raise them and
take care of them
what do your daughters do for work they
work for road safe
which is what it's a traffic system a
flag for the power company
okay and where's your ex-wife
after she got involved in drugs i guess
she's on toller i don't i don't
have no associations with him she's on
what she lives on toler creek they call
it
and but i have no association with her
what's the most important lesson you've
learned in your life well
how times how hard times get
you know times get hard sometimes
but you know like i said here on the
farm we do her hogs we do her chickens
you know we can live a long time but
people have to go to the store to get
their next meal
i don't know what's going to happen but
you got
to keep going on and on because
life goes on you know you struggle for
something
it'll get better as time goes it'll get
better
i just thank god that we've got enough
we can live
all right randy thank you so much for
sharing your story
thank you for coming and good luck with
your daughters and your what you're the
rest of your life
and i want you to come back uh if it's
just a visit when we kill hogs i welcome
you to come back
and eat some fresh hog meat on the
okofar
and enjoy with us i love you you don't
have to family i mean
you're welcome to come back and just sit
around and enjoy the food with us
that sounds wonderful thank you so much
thank you for coming
all right randy thank you very much
thank you all right okay